[Musique]
au delà du voyage
éliminé en demi finale du championnat
français de 1re division les templiers
entendez bien finir la saison avec
chrome os une coupe entre les mains
seulement l'homme fort de l'équipe pérez
mathieson montreux dès le début des
signes de faiblesse le quarterback
américain peine à trouver ses marques
sur une pelouse détrempée par un orage
survenu plus tôt dans l'après-midi une
opportunité vite saisi par les
mercenaires qui inscrit de quatre
minutes plus tard un premier touchdown
grâce à jérôme castle berry aussitôt
transformé au pied par peter muller
comme tout au long de la rencontre les
allemands progressent qu'ensuite et
garde par yard sans qu'aucune
intervention efficace des templiers de
les frêles si bien que le numéro 7
trouve une nouvelle fois le chemin de
l'en but adverse
le break est ensuite définitivement
acquis grâce à se lancer de 40 yards un
début de second quart temps dépassé en
défense les templiers vont finalement
reprendre goût à la taca grâce à perez
mathieson que l'on retrouve ici plus
inspiré après avoir rapproché les siens
à 2 yards de la endzone et inscrit ses
premiers points
mais malgré une nouvelle action juste
avant la mi temps le score est déjà de
14 à 35
12 heures
qu'est ce que vous avez dit à la
mi-temps de rester ensemble si on y
croit tout ira bien
un conseil simple qui finalement ne paye
pas si l'on en croit la dispersion de la
défense sur cet essai allemand on
retiendra tout de même côté templiers
cette course de 15 yards de jérémy là je
pense qu on a fait trop d'erreurs en
défense on a raté des plaquages à des
moments clés ils ont pas eu vraiment de
gros jeux ils avançaient petit à petit
et c'est là qu'on n'a pas réussi à les
arrêter quand on a eu des occasions les
arrêtés on les a pas saisies ont raté
quelques plaquages on a tous fait des
erreurs les uns après les autres
moi le premier les premières
participations en finale de la fa cup
c'est une très belle saison mais on joue
pas pour perdre donc on voulait gagner
on est au summum de ce concours
pratiqués actuellement vu le nombre de
joueurs vu le gabarit des joueurs les
vraiment summum bêtise ça viendra plus
tard
[Musique]